we begin this morning with what's
expected to be an historic march on
Washington half a million people from
all corners of the country will flood
the Capitol to say they've had enough of
gun violence the March for our lives
rallies being organized by students who
survived the shooting at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in parkland
Florida 14 of their classmates and three
school staff members were killed and
last month's attack and since then
student activists have been calling for
stricter gun control measures today
they're hoping their message will be
amplified at a rally that runs straight
through the nerve center of the nation's
leadership Jeff Piquet's is on Capitol
Hill Jeff good morning good morning
police in this city are bracing for
those five hundred thousand people to
gather here today for this rally in the
five and a half weeks since the shooting
at in parkland at the high school
students have become activists and
they've been successful keeping the gun
control debate in the headlines as it
will be today with this protest which
will be one of the biggest in Washington
in recent memory
[Music]
at a concert to benefit gun control
groups last night some of the Stoneman
Douglas students took to the stage their
message the push to tighten gun laws
doesn't end with today's rally go back
home you'll make a change go make a
difference find what you can do write
your Congressman do all that make a
difference in the world
cuz this can't happen again the seeds of
their activism were planted in a mass
shooting back on February 14th when
suspected shooter Nicholas Cruz opened
fire at their Florida High School police
say crews used a legally purchased
assault weapon in the shooting but the
19 year old had been on the radar of law
enforcement including multiple tips that
he might have been planning a school
shooting day some of the Stoneman
Douglas students began their campaign of
pressuring leaders on gun control since
February 14th students around the
country have continued this call one
month to the day after the shooting
thousands of students nationwide
participated in a walkout from their
school the CBS News poll out this
morning finds Americans by an almost
two-to-one margin support young people
speaking out on guns and safety we're
the next generation who's gonna get to
vote so we're gonna be able to vote them
out of office if they don't do anything
to protect us students from around the
country are gathering here is part of a
student-led movement that began in the
days and hours after the shooting
this all started at my house we've just
been there I haven't seen her in like 20
minutes the original goals of never
again were to make one center where we
could all be together and grieve and
demand change in one spot we were trying
to focus on what would get the most
people behind us who can we send out to
which interviews okay everybody's on
computers everybody's making calls
everybody's trying to remember the
organizers of today's March are calling
on Congress to ban the sale of assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines and
tighten background checks to prevent
dangerous individuals from buying guns
online or a gun shows but not all of
those affected by the tragedy in
parkland think this is the best way
forward andrew pollock whose daughter
meadow was killed at Stoneman Douglas
says school security should be the
priority it's great that the kids are
out there together and they have a voice
you know I feel that pain but if they're
gonna concentrate on gun control I think
they're wasting that time what we need
right now in this country is school
safety and there are a number of
so-called sibling marches planned for
cities across the country today similar
to what's happening here but not as big
just to give you an idea of how savvy
the organizers of this march are they
have set up voting registration booths
that is their way of making lasting
change based on what's happening here
today
rina yeah clearly not just one day just
the gays on Capitol Hill thank you Jeff
well CBS will have live reports from
today's March as well as on CBS n our 24
hours streaming news channel and also
our special documentary 39 days will air
tonight at 8:00 7:00 central right here
on CBS